goie blew my mind with their new Glide
Ultra Edition panels these gaming lights
look absolutely incredible and they are
by far the best hexagon lights in the
whole market now my son NOA is a huge
goie fan already he has multiple lights
and he was so excited to see what GOI
sent us so shout out to goie for
sponsoring this one now these lights
launch on September 25th so you guys can
use the link down below and they have a
very Innovative design and they are made
to have the best 3D lighting effect out
there we have two color options right
now we have the meteor gray which has a
matte look with a special layer that
gives you more gentle lights and the
lunar light which uses a transparent
shell for more bright and colorful
lights now what you guys see on camera
looks incredible but in the real world
it looks even better my camera couldn't
even capture the Vibrance the colors and
the brightness that your eyes can see so
they are insane and that is because each
panel has 33 integrated circuits that
control the inner frame the outer frame
and the surface which makes for this
amazing 3d effect whereas the main
competitor well they have nine
integrated circuits instead of 33 they
also have three times the LEDs built
into each panel and because of that you
get to dis playay three different
effects and colors at the same time so
you get really seamless Dynamic lighting
effects now the Glide Ultra works with
Google home it works with Alexa and it
works with their goie AI gaming sync box
if you want to sync it to your game
which is cool now I have to be honest
when I saw all of the different
connections on the back of each panel I
was slightly overwhelmed especially
because you don't have to use one of
their pre-design that do look really
cool you can actually create your own
and I thought setup was going to take a
long time now we actually created our
own design and we combined both the
meteor gray and the lunar white for our
design and we took some time using their
little cutouts to put them on the wall
see what design looked well we swapped
it around a couple times and we found
something that we loved now Noah my son
did a lot of this install himself why
will we were filming so if a 10-year-old
could do it you can as well you start by
taking out the power adapter with the
physical control switch and plugging
that in and then you open up the goie
app that's designed for phones now my
son does not have a smartphone yet but
he has an iPad and it works just fine
and then you just add it to your goie
account from there you get a full
installation video and it wants you to
plug in each panel just to make sure
that it's working great which ours did
of course and the app will give give you
some recommended designs to choose from
and you can even preview how they will
look in different scenarios now we
played around with some of our own
custom designs which is super easy to do
and then we started by plugging in the
power cable now the app works incredible
they did such a good job and it
literally shows you where to plug in the
power and then where to plug in the
first connectors and you just go step by
step connecting and attaching one panel
at a time you hold it down to your wall
and the adhesive actually holds very
well and they even give you a bubble
level to make sure that you start off
nice and straight and then we started to
explore the app in all of the different
options now I was super impressed with
the presets I think they have about 60
of them they have a huge variation of
different patterns and colors it's not
like they just give you a bunch of
buttons where just a few colors change
the dynamic effects were crazy the
different designs which kind of part of
the panels were lighting up it was so
cool they have these different
categories that you can choose from and
they even have a music mode where the
panels will uh Flash and change
depending on what you're playing you
have a lot of different options that you
could tweak and this was super cool you
can also go in and customize make your
own colors and different effects and so
if you want to play around with it like
my son does with his previous gov lights
there's so much customization that you
could do now these gaming lights can
really upgrade your gaming experience
your Ambience and you don't have to use
them just for a computer setup you can
really use them anywhere for a nice
accent that really kind of steps up your
space so you guys saw his setup there at
his desk I think looks incredible
everybody in my family was very
impressed not only the other kids but my
wife was shocked by how awesome it looks
so if you guys want to get something
that looks absolutely unique amazing
with a ton of customization and really
high quality go ahead and check him out
down in the description below there is
nothing better that is available on the
market thank you guys for watching go
ahead and click that Circle above check
out one of those great videos right over
there and I will see you in the next
[Music]
one